Reggie's really good at accents and I
thought it'd be kind of fun to just
throw different things at you and let's
start with a French accent what's your
French accent like depends on uh if you
are you know having a good time or not
all the time we uh we tied to uh have a
good time and I told like this but I
don't know where it's from exactly so
maybe someone who's moved to London and
they live there but I'm not no they
might be from like like bletchford or
something there are times when I can do
an Irish accent but it's it's a bit [__]
I mean New York is easy going down like
Midtown whatever and you and you stop
and then you're seeing this guy and
you're like why are you doing this you
[__] you're [__] driving me in
shame I'm looking at you and you're just
looking at me and I'm like what are we
doing here you're gonna move I'm gonna
move who's gonna move I'm walking from
California it's like hey what's going on
yeah so um you want to go to Montecito I
was going to go there the other day
anything that has an o at the end of it
like burrito or whatever for sure